all of those candidates that I went and
supported that none of that was planned
beforehand and my phone just started
ringing off the hook coming from
different candidates across the country
who recognize exactly what we just
talked about is that there are a lot of
folks who whether they identify as
independent or not are
independent-minded people and who are
maybe struggling especially in those
last weeks before the election about
trying to decide who they want to cast
their vote for given their frustrations
with people in both political parties
and uh and so that was that was where
the requests I got came from uh frankly
was it was Republicans there were there
were no Democrats I think who had the
courage to even those who I know agree
with my same frustrations and concerns
with the Democratic party
um didn't have the courage to to step up
and actually say those things
foreign
Rubin and joining me today is the host
of the Tulsi gabbard show a former U.S
congresswoman from the great state of
Hawaii and now a former Democrat Tulsi
gabbard welcome back to the Reuben
report nice to see you my friend it's
been a little while it has been a little
while Chelsea this is my first interview
of uh 2023 so you really got to bring it
today I know you're busy you're doing
your Tucker thing all the time but I
know you gotta you gotta bring it for me
can you do that uh no I'll do my best
I'll do my best
let's start real quick I don't want to
belabor the point with leaving the
Democrat Party and and you've obviously
talked about it quite a bit and I was
kind of trying to nudge you in my own
way for a while is there anything you
want to comment on related to that at
this point you left you campaigned with
some Republicans obviously the wave
didn't happen but we are seeing sort of
wholesale changes on both sides right
now
anything as we start the year off on
that front that's on your mind
yeah sure you know I I as I think back
to uh when I announced I left the
Democratic party on October 11th and I
listed out some very specific and clear
reasons why I made that decision to
leave the Democratic party what's wrong
with today's Democratic party and my
decision to become an independent and
frankly uh the things that we have seen
play out since then and are continuing
to play out unfortunately just further
um highlight and underline those very
real concerns that I have and and
frankly since making that announcement
I've heard from a lot of people
um maybe some people who are well-known
names but it's also a lot of just
everyday Americans who have expressed
how they have felt or feeling the same
frustrations that I am and that
um they they were grateful to to have
somebody actually voice those uh in a
way that a lot of folks across the
country heard so you know there's a lot
happening as you know very well Dave
below the surface that doesn't make it
into you know the big headlines of the
mainstream media at all but it really is
this underlying frustration and frankly
it's not just with the Democratic party
as we're seeing happen now it's with the
Republican party as well and frankly it
points to just the American people
pissed off frustrated and
disenfranchised with those who are in
power period what was it like for you
when you because you basically made the
announcement and then you started
campaigning with some people I mean when
you were going to these rallies
obviously people people liked having you
there and all that stuff but you do have
some differences with traditional
Republicans was was there tension there
or I found there was no attention that
yeah people just get over it yeah there
was no tension and I think it was and
and sometimes those that statement was
made well we're not going to agree on
everything which which we're not who
actually does uh but but all of those
candidates that I went and supported
that none of that was planned beforehand
and uh my phone just started ringing off
the hook coming from different
candidates across the country who
recognize exactly what we just talked
about is that there are a lot of folks
who whether they identify as independent
or not are independent-minded people and
who are maybe struggling especially in
those last weeks before the election
about trying to decide who they want to
cast their vote for given their
frustrations with people in both
political parties and and so that was
that was where the requests I got came
from uh frankly was it was Republicans
there were there were no Democrats I
think who had the courage to even those
who I know agree with my same
frustrations and concerns with the
Democratic party
um didn't have the courage to to step up
and actually say those things uh so so
the request I got came from Republicans
um across the spectrum of the Republican
party and regardless of differences on
other issues ultimately I chose to go
out and support those who value freedom
and who are committed to the
Constitution and who recognize the need
for leaders to step up and lead and
speak the truth whether that is about
leaders in the Democratic party the
Republican party but actually step up
and speak for and fight for the American
people does that seem like uh sort of an
obvious extension of the way that your
campaign when you were running for
president sort of ended in that you were
the last one besides Biden everyone else
cut the deal whatever they had to do to
get into the what would be the future
Administration you you stuck and fought
you didn't cut the deals yet Hillary
Clinton literally claiming you were in
essence a Russian operative so that this
where you sit today as an independent
seems fairly obvious
yeah I mean I've always been an
independent-minded person
um you know for as long as I you know
chose to become a Democrat back in
2002 when I first ran for state house
here in Hawaii because at that time I
was drawn to the Democratic party
because especially here in Hawaii I saw
a party that was really rooted in uh in
inclusiveness and civil liberties and
standing up for free speech and
diversity of thought and the big tent
party and and
um and frankly there were a lot of
voices in the Democratic party that were
voices for peace uh that's changed
almost wholesale since then but from
that point throughout as long as I've
been in and out of politics since 2002
I've always been an independent-minded
person always really done my best to try
to make decisions policy decisions are
otherwise based on how what what's in
the best interest of the American people
what's in the best interest of the
country so let me ask you one that's
that's actually purely on policy because
I mentioned to my locals Community this
morning learning that I was having you
on today and basically my audience loves
you even even the people that are say
more right than you are they say okay
well we can have an honest conversation
with her she's trying to talk about this
stuff all good the one that keeps coming
up with you is they still are afraid you
are going to come after their guns if
you were to go back into government that
that they see as somehow the piece of
you that is still a Democrat or
something like that I'm honestly not
even totally sure of your your policies
on on all of that so I just leave it to
you to answer the answer their question
sure uh I've always supported the Second
Amendment and the right to bear arms
what I will say has changed over the
last few years is you know previously I
you know growing up in Hawaii we uh have
one of the most restrictive laws one of
the most states with restrictive laws in
the country as it pertains to gun
ownership it takes weeks to be able to
go and apply for and get a permit and
actually be able to take the firearm
that you purchased home with you it's a
pretty it's a pretty tough and rigorous
process so I didn't grow up around you
know shooting a lot of guns and a
different culture than maybe a lot of
folks have in other parts of the country
um and so as I looked at what I felt
were Common Sense policies around uh you
know making sure that we can try to
prevent mass shootings in schools and so
forth that was what was informing my
judgment and my decision making as a
member of Congress
the thing that has changed in a very
very
impactful way for me is seeing how
the danger of this of of any one in
government
um overstepping their boundaries and
violating our rights and really
understanding in a visceral way our
Founders intent
to put the Second Amendment in place was
not only to defend your your safety and
your your family protect your family
against those who seek to do you harm
but also for us as a people as a line of
defense to protect ourselves against a
tyrannical government and when you look
at was what has happened since 2020
in so many respects we see more and more
authoritarian leaning decisions and
intentions and policies being put
forward by Our Own federal government
and you start to see again why the
Second Amendment is important that's
what I started to see and better
understand uh there are a number of
things that happened there was the
Supreme Court
decision that was made with regard to
the New York Concealed Carry Permit case
um I read actually read through a lot of
the comments and the remarks that went
on throughout that case and also the
decision and there were some things
there that uh
provided for me some some fundamental
insight and caused me to look look at
the second one in a way that frankly I'd
never had and very simply which is
um
the Second Amendment must be protected
as strongly and fiercely as we protect
the First Amendment if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
mindless dribble check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification Bell